today's topic
do all black people think alike no next
topic
[Music]
all right looking at the guy in the
front i already know he's ethiopian yup
one look at that forehead you're part of
the tribe you already know rihanna shout
out let's go
i did not click this video
[ __ ] i did not click this video i am
baffled
what is this
jubilee wow watch
oh you ain't [ __ ] for this one oh
[ __ ] okay listen i know
kendra works at jubilee so i'm gonna
just assume
this question came as a joke oh
jubilee i'ma assume
okay sometimes you know album briefs
sometimes they're really just
mean for no reason jubilee i'm gonna
just assume this is a joke jubilee
no no no no no no no you know what
sometimes
if you just go really far sometimes it's
just funny so you know what
listen i'm gonna let it slide let's just
have a little left oh my god
all right i'm sure it's gonna get better
[Laughter]
i thoroughly enjoy fried chicken
i'm sorry this is no no no
i just don't really like fried food i'm
not really a fan of chicken i've never
ate it so
you've never had fried chicken
[Music]
oh
quick little break if you guys are
enjoying this you're having a good
little laugh like comment subscribe
right if you want bonus content we have
exclusive videos up on patreon right now
do we a lot of it's uncensored go enjoy
i refuse i refuse
oh
[ __ ] oh
i'm crying okay oh my god
she said she said i never had fried
chicken
pot there's a five second silence and
they're like
you never had fried chicken oh nick no
no okay this is not satire okay today's
video is sponsored oh wait
all right you already know okay we're
ready today's video is sponsored by blue
chew
say it with us now blue chip it's time
for you to gain more confidence
and longer lasting experiences in the
bedroom with bluetooth tablets okay
you deserve better she deserves harder
get it together
bars listen bluechu is a unique online
service
that offers you the same active
ingredients
as a viagra in cialis but in a chewable
form and at a fraction of the cost
and one of the best parts is that you
know bluetooth it's an online service so
you don't need to go to the doctor and
have an awkward conversation with that
person
all you gotta do is go to bluetooth.com
you just need to consult with one of
their medical licensed professionals
and once you're approved we just ship it
to your door and we got a special deal
just for you guys you can try bluetooth
for free when you use promo code abba
all right and all you gotta do is pay
for the five dollar shipping that's
bluechew.com using promo code abba and
get your first month
free so a big shout out to bluetooth for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
this is gonna be the most surface level
questions ever three
two one
i feel like i'm always on the wrong side
of the room
would you guys be offended if i had
dreads since i'm biracial since i'm half
black and half white so where is the
line like if someone's
a quarter black i'm not gonna sit there
and come to your face and be like
you're not 100 black therefore you can't
like
that's not my place however um
if you're a white person and you have
dreads in your hair it's like what
what what does that mean to you kanye
west
is invited to the cookout
is there a note from jubilee about this
video did i miss something
there's got to be something i'm missing
here at first this [ __ ] was funny
now it's just beautiful i'm gonna just
skip this question no no don't don't
don't we're doing this we're not
skipping it what's happening
watch it who cares do you think the next
question's gonna be better
it started off with fried chicken [ __ ]
i act
differently around people who aren't
black
three two one
i agree that i act differently around
people that aren't black just because
like
corporate america doesn't want to hear
me talking
uh doesn't hear me speaking in slang and
i
am not happy about it like i wish that
it was different but i feel like i need
to do to fit into that group
i strongly disagree i am me wherever i
go i'm a proud
black man and i'ma speak my truth every
day of the week
if you don't like it [ __ ] it ain't on me
that's on you and i feel like it's a
disservice
to anyone i'm around and from not being
my authentic self
because my white friends might want to
hang out me because i'm black
what does he do he's probably like a
comedian or something if you have any
kind of corporate office job like
sorry but a lot of a vernacular it's not
it's normal it's like that's anybody
when you're around the job you speak
differently you pick up the phone like
hey what up man
no white or black you're going to pick
up the phone message
rogers there's a way
of saying things you know it's normal at
any job but you don't speak like that
yeah they want some flavor so if i go in
being something totally different
there's two different things there's
different things one thing is are you
changing yourself
are you changing how you're
communicating who you are and i'm
changing how i'm communicating who i am
and i still remain the same
like do you have a white voice do i have
a white voice i know i know col i'm a
black man trust me
i every every black person growing up in
america can cold switch
then you need to move a little bit but
but here's the thing
here's the thing the question was do i
act different
when i'm in different surroundings and
no but see how would i ever be accepted
if i'm always code switching that means
i'm always
acquiescing to something else you see
what i'm saying so in order to be
accepted you got to bring you
do you guys when when you say code
switch do you mean you change the actual
words you say or do you mean you change
the tone of your voice
i change how i say it and i change what
i say i will i'll walk into a business
meeting different than how i walk into
the basketball court so that's me
changing to fit the scenario
to benefit the end goal and i don't view
that as a negative i view that as me
focusing on what the end goal is
but i feel like society has made
american society has made black people
operate in that fashion because nobody
asks white people to cold switch
they can break they can be white in
america china
wherever white people do go twitch
not as much as black people not as much
imma give you that
not as much and it's not as drastic as
black people
because we go from one to another
spectrum real quick
but yeah people in general code switch
if you got
friends family and work you're not gonna
talk to your friends
your family and your work people the
same way
normally speaking if you're like well me
shut the [ __ ] up you're an exception i'm
not talking about you
normally speaking most people are gonna
talk to these three different
aspects differently and that's just
normal i am proud
well all right y'all have a long time
for y'all i'm glad that we all strongly
agree
yeah yeah i love that you know we can
have these discussions and like still go
home knowing that
we're family and i and i love all right
that was trash
okay i just want to say this is season
one episode one i was not aware until i
looked at the description
and so i'm gonna give them a pass
because it's their first time doing it
and i just think they missed the mark
completely
i think they missed the mark so badly
though that it almost made me
like how how did you think those were
good questions but again
it was their first try they started to
fry you started with fried chicken
hopefully someone told you about that it
was nonsense and how nonsense it was
and you saw a reaction we're not the
only one michael jackson
i'm here with you no no
but again it's the first episode and of
their recent videos i've enjoyed quite a
lot of them
so they've probably made a lot of
strides yeah let's you know let's put
that in the balance we just leave it at
that i don't know why that means but
whole leaf that was terrible compared to
the other spectrums that was trash
fresh all right that was my sew it in a
dumpster that was not good
zero insightful and i think it's a shame
because the cast looked interesting
and they look like they had different
opinions so i definitely think um they
should revisit this in the future and
redo this topic properly please
but other than that properly don't
include fried chicken or watermelon and
that thing or kanye west we don't care
ask harder questions that's probably
what i would say hey that's it for today
[Music]
oh